what the next Labor government will do
he's determined to be a clean break with
the past the labor leader today talking
to Charities about the cost of living
trying to move on from questions about
the woman dominating the headlines one
of Labor's most recognizable faces Diane
Abbott in the spotlight for claiming in
The Observer that Jewish people
experience Prejudice but not racism in
my view what she said was to be
condemned it was anti-semitic it's
absolutely right that we acted as
swiftly as we did that's the change that
you've seen in the labor party but do I
condemn what she said I absolutely
condemn what she said Diane Abbott has
been a Trailblazer in British Politics
the first black woman elected to
Parliament she's spoken out about the
racist abuse that she's received now
suspended from the party herself the big
question is will she be reinstated in
time for the next election the problem
with labor parties disciplinary
processes they are very factional
they're very much about who you know and
what happens and it's within the gift of
the leader to suspend the whip as we've
seen the Jeremy corbyn if dianaba isn't
reinstated do you think
that could be a politically motivated
decision by kirst armor if she is
expelled or the whip permanently
withdrawn
then clearly that is a fractional point
because look at the comparison with
other MPS who have said offensive things
in a kind of similar vein they've been
allowed back in often without even an
investigation
the key difference between Jeremy corbyn
and Diane Abbott was a swift apology
comparisons have been made too with
labor MP Rupert Huck who was recently
reinstated after calling quasi quateng
superficially black a labor front
bencher Steve Reed stayed in his job
after apologizing for a deleted tweet
calling a Jewish businessman a puppet
master kirst armor has gone to Great
Lengths to show that he has changed the
labor party could he therefore relish a
prolonged battle with such a
recognizable figure on the left of the
party or will it instead be too painful
a battle that shows that the party is
still distracted by infighting any
decision the kirst armor makes about
Diane Abbott will undoubtedly be
controversial
to me this takes me straight back to the
labor party in Detroit with the labor
party shame where the equality of the
Human Rights Commission ruled that labor
had been anti-semitic a terrible
situation and something none of us want
to go back to
not long ago they were cabinet
colleagues now Diane Abbott's political
career hangs in the balance and
kierstama faces another test of how far
he's willing to go to break with the
party's past Ali Fortescue Sky News
Westminster